>> UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT IS URGING THE WEST TO
PROVIDE MORE WEAPONS AFTER THE
LATEST ROUND OF RUSSIAN
ATTACKS.
UKRAINE'S MILITARY SAYS IT SHOT
DOWN 47, 70 MISSILES LAUNCHED
AT UKRAINE, ALONG WITH 18
IRANIAN MADE DRONES, AT LEAST
11 PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
MISSILES THAT DID MAKE IT
THROUGH TARGETED ENERGY
FACILITIES, AND HIT SOME
RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
SUBSTANTIAL DAMAGE TO --
IS REPORTED.
MEANTIME, FIGHTING IS
INTENSIFYING IN MANY CITIES.
INCLUDING BACK, FRED PLEITGEN
HAS MORE ON THAT FOR US.
>> UKRAINE'S TANKS, TAKING AIM
AT THE INVADING RUSSIANS.
KYIV'S FORCES, RALLYING TO TRY
TO HALT A MASSIVE ASSAULT ON
BAKHMUT.
THE CITY WHERE THERE ARE STILL
STILL SOME 6000 CIVILIANS, HAS
BECOME A CAULDRON OF FIRE.
FROM THIS VANTAGE POINT, YOU
CAN BOTH SEE AND HEAR JUST HOW
FIERCE THE FIGHTING IS.
YOU CAN HEAR IMPACT FROM HEAVY
WEAPONS, NOT JUST EVERY MINUTE,
BUT LITERALLY EVERY SECOND.
A UKRAINIAN SAYS THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE POURING A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF PERSONNEL AND WEAPONS
INTO THIS AREA BECAUSE THEY
SEEM TO WANT TO TAKE BAKHMUT AT
NEARLY ANY COST.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF REGULAR
RUSSIAN TROOPS FIGHTING AROUND
BAKHMUT NOW.
BUT THE UKRAINIANS SAY, IT'S
STILL THE WAGNER PRIVATE
MILITARY COMPANY THAT'S LEADING
THE CHARGE.
WITH WAVES OF FIGHTERS TRYING
TO STORM UKRAINIAN POSITIONS
BOTH NORTH AND SOUTH OF THE
CITY, AS WELL AS SPECIALIZED
FORCES LIKE THESE SNIPERS,
CLAIMING TO HAVE KILLED
UKRAINIAN SOLDIER.
>> [INTERPRETER]
ALL I COULD SEE WAS A CURTAIN
WINDOW, THIS SNIPER SAYS.
THE PERSON WAS PAIRED WITH ME
SAW A THERMAL OUTLINE AND I
JUST DETERMINED WHERE TO SHOOT.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> WAGNER'S BOSS, YEVGENY
PRIGOZHIN, OFTEN TOUTS HIS
MALICIOUS SUCCESSES, BUT THE
COST IS IMMENSE.
THIS IS A WAGNER CEMETERY IN
THE KRASNODAR REGION OF
SOUTHERN RUSSIA.
ROW AFTER ROW OF FRESH GRAVES,
A DISPOSABLE FORCE USED TO TAKE
JUST A FEW KILOMETERS OF LAND.
WAGNER ACKNOWLEDGES RECRUITING
PRISONERS STRAIGHT OUT OF JAIL
AND THROWING THEM ON THE
BATTLEFIELD WITH MINIMAL
TRAINING AND ONLY SLIM CHANCES
OF SURVIVAL.
THAT SAME INDIFFERENCE SHOWN IN
RUSSIAN STRIKES THAT KILL AND
MAIM UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS EVERY
DAY.
THESE FOLKS ARE CLEANING UP
AFTER A RUSSIAN MISSILE LANDED
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD NEAR
BAKHMUT.
>> [INTERPRETER]
WE WERE GETTING HEATING FROM
THE HEATING PLANT WHICH WAS HIT,
YURI TELLS ME.
YESTERDAY AT 3:00, IT WAS
DESTROYED, SO NOW WE HAVE NO
ELECTRICITY, NO HEATING, WE
HAVE NOTHING.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> AND A FEW MILES AWAY, ONE
PERSON WAS KILLED IN ANOTHER
DENSELY POPULATED AREA.
SOME OF LONG DISTANCE DRONES
AND MISSILES THAT RUSSIA USES
TO ATTACK UKRAINE COME DOWN
RIGHT NEAR CIVILIAN AREAS.
THIS HERE IS ONLY A FEW YARDS
AWAY FROM A KINDERGARTEN.
HOWEVER, OTHERS ARE USED TO
DIRECTLY TARGET CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
MORE THAN 50 MISSILES FIRED
JUST ON THURSDAY.
AND WHILE MANY OF THEM WERE
INTERCEPTED BY UKRAINIAN AIR
DEFENSES, SOME WERE NOT BROUGHT
DOWN, ADDING TO THE DAILY TOLL
OF DESTRUCTION.
THE MISSILE TERROR, MORE
MOTIVATION FOR UKRAINE'S
SOLDIERS AROUND BAKHMUT TO
STAND THEIR GROUND AND BRING
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INVASION TO A
STANDSTILL.
>> FRED PLEITGEN, CNN, BACK.
LOOK >> WE JUST HEARD FRED'S
REPORT, THE INCESSANT
BOMBARDMENT, SPECIFICALLY IN
BACK ABOUT, AND OF COURSE,
THERE'S BEEN ADVISED TO THE
UKRAINIANS FOCUS ELSEWHERE,
COULD YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE
FRONTLINES HERE, SAM.
.
>> YOU HAVE AN 800 MILE
FRONTLINE AT LEAST STRETCHING
FROM THE NORTH OF THE COUNTRY,
AND A GREAT YOU SHAPE ALL THE
WAY AROUND TO THE SOUTH,
FIGHTING HAS BEEN CONCENTRATED
IN THE EAST, AROUND BACK MOOT,
BUT ALSO, TOWNS TO THE NORTH
AND SOUTH OF THERE, IN THAT
AREA, THE SAME THAT PUSHES THE
FURTHEST INTO TERRITORY THAT IS
ALREADY BEEN GRABBED BY RUSSIA,
BUT THERE ARE, THERE HAS BEEN
AN INCREASE IN OPERATIONS BY
BOTH SIDES, BUT NOTABLY, BY
RUSSIA LOW-LEVEL OPERATIONS ON
THE, FRONT IN THE SOUTH, AND
CONTINUE, IT'S ALMOST
CONTINUOUS BOMBARDMENT OF THE
RECENTLY RELATIVELY RECENTLY,
LIBERATED CITY OF --
WHERE THE RUSSIANS ARE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE RIVER, NOW
POUNDING THE CIVILIAN CITY.
THE ANTICIPATION IS THOUGH,
THAT THERE COULD BE AN
OFFENSIVE FROM THE RUSSIANS IN
THE SPRING, IF NOT SOONER THAN
THAT.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE SAYING, THEY
NEED MORE WEAPONS, MORE
CAPABILITY TO PROTECT THEIR
SKIES, BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
ASSAULT THEIR OWN, OR CONDUCT
THEIR OWN ASSAULTS, TO REGAIN
MOMENTUM THAT WAS SO EFFECTIVE
IN LIBERATING --
BEFORE, THAT A LARGE AREA
AROUND KYIV.
NOT THAT FAR FROM WHERE FRED
WAS REPORTING THERE.
ELENI, NOW THEY'RE ALSO
POINTING OUT THIS LATEST WAVE
OF MISSILE ATTACKS, IT INCLUDED
AT LEAST 2 MISSILES.
THESE ARE HYPERSONIC, ULTRA
SUPERSONIC IF YOU'D LIKE
MISSILES, LAUNCHED FROM
AIRCRAFT THAT EVADE ALL OF THE
CAPABILITIES THAT THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE --
AND REINFORCES FROM THE
UKRAINIAN PERSPECTIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE SPOKESPERSON,
THEY HAVE THE PATRIOT, AND
OTHER SOPHISTICATED AIR
DEFENSES BECAUSE THE VERY
STATE-OF-THE-ART NEW MISSILES
DEVELOPED BY RUSSIA, THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS ALSO TRYING TO
DEVELOP.
WE UNDERSTAND, THEY'RE ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO STOP, BECAUSE
THEY FLY SO, FAST AND THEY'RE
HIGHLY MANOEUVRABLE.
THEY'RE ALSO CAPABLE OF
DELIVERING A WARHEAD OF SOME
500 KILOGRAMS, ABOUT 1100
POUNDS OF HIGH EXPLOSIVE.
ULTIMATELY A NUCLEAR WARHEAD.
YOU HAVE THIS VERY STRANGE
SITUATION YOU'VE GOT VERY
HIGHLY SOPHISTICATED 24 CENTURY
TYPE WEAPONS BY WHAT RUSSIA
FROM TIME TO TIME, IN AS FRED
WAS REPORTED, THERE THESE HUMAN
WAVE ATTACKS BEING CONDUCTED BY
CONSCRIPT AND SEMI CONSCRIPTED
PRISONERS.
UNDER THE WAGNER GROUP.
WITH REPORTEDLY, AND WE DON'T
HAVE INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION
OF, THIS PUNISHED VITAL USED TO
THE REAR, FORCING YOUNG RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS TO ATTACK IN HUMAN
WAYS.
IF YOU'RE COMING OUT UGLY WAR
AT GROUND LEVEL, AND
INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS AND IT'S
SOPHISTICATION IN THE AIR,
ELENI.
>> YES, IT'S INTENSIFYING, AND
OF COURSE WE'RE SEEING DAMAGE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AS
WELL.
SAM KILEY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.